to watch the games oh yeah you see how
how uh
palchik shook graybles hand at the end
of that well you know you mean very well
very well
I'm very grateful for every room yeah
but you know why right he played music
yeah you used like their guys kappa team
very smart guy so he out bill check bill
chest so crazy with the taking the
delayed penalties and the punts and all
that that's that's of pay explain not to
me because I could see Belcher corn
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] here I'm gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] but what was he doing
till I don't understand what that won't
because he'd because so they were up I
think by three I figure what it was but
they they want to give Tom Brady the
ball back with the least amount of time
possible so if you take a penalty it
runs off 15 seconds than the clock the
clock continues to run so he's just
draining time so he took the penalty
right so he ran the clock all the way
down took time out took thing the guy
took a penalty so another 15 seconds so
he's just trying to run down time and
that guy was offside yeah he's just run
down time it's like it's like a crinkle
in the system Wow it's a page out of
Bill I would spellcheck so mad because
you got our hustle your lap um okay in
fables youth righteous in a loss oh no
you know but I mean have you ever what's
the HP of us the I think it's like even
the Saban Belcher it's just Omashu
biggest egos in the world talking about
football and how great they are
over and I'll I'll a so I think well I
like Saban I think both are fantastic
yeah but you watch that you like it's
awful it's just like they're they're
both that can it's just they're not nice
Scott no it'd be great if they should
have two of their assistants talking
about them I don't want to see those two
timeout how great each other are it's
very strange so it's not Nick saying how
great bill is it's Nick town bill how
Gradius and Bill tell Nick how great he
is you know I'm saying like it's Bill
saying how he's the best coach in at the
NFL and Nick saying how he's the best
coaching it's it's so strange man wow
I'm like huge amazing Oh Saban has the
biggest ego really and I think that's
why Tom Brady won't be back to New
England human-built checked hate each
other what they eat each other toxic
relationship is that true
but they look what they've done together
yeah how can you hate each other I did
not know that is that a fact that they
hate each other
I thought any well-known friend oh god
no no how into the owner Kraft and Brady
your best friend there that that's only
reason that's what keeps them that the
and how long is Belichick and Brady been
off for a hot second man Wow I have a
question about Brady at 43 almost now
supplements
well yes I wasn't gonna ask that well
yeah you think he just drink those
avocado shakes but again why why
wouldn't you take starts lon
heh-heh no issue with that at all me
neither because he's 43 and he's great
and not this kind of game where his he
looks like he's throwing it everything
is right but everyone he's playing in
son same [ __ ] here's what I think is
interesting as the season went on and
it's not you can't land at his feet but
they went four and four even though they
were you know so they were they were
they were undefeated they ain't no and
then they went as you get older you it
might be a microsecond but I would
imagine you get a little slower you get
a little off the draw you get you you
just you're making here a second slow
yes yeah and that could be as perfect as
he is I think that might have some do a
bluff so he didn't haven't he's not you
don't have anybody lines like this line
he's the only reason they got to know is
his defense really good and they have
good game playing good coaching and they
have a great offense coordinator but
it's how is he this Brady have to do
with at on hot on it runs that
[ __ ] he does 21 years he's been
big boy but they have Adelman you know
and he was injured in in and out they
really have anybody see that's why he's
the one of the best or the best
quarterback I don't think he's the the
greatest football player of time he's
the best quarterback of all time I think
Jay writes the greatest football player
of all time look at the numbers no one's
ever gonna tear his rice yeah I know
it's never gonna touch it he's like
Wayne Gretzky in hockey really yeah you
people forget you look at like oh [ __ ]
he was good yeah your view if you look
at last far as statistically who's the
greatest professional athlete ever like
competing yeah it's Wayne Gretzky yeah
yeah as far as just like dominating
right
it's also not silt with the physical
tools it's well for I mean he was so
fast
denis leary tells a story about he's
with Wayne Gretzky and and I'm trying to
remember the story but it was uh but he
said he said do you think they were at
the half half half court line you know I
don't know how to either do this and he
said do you think you could hit the top
goal post you know from here like how
accurate do you think you'd be and Wayne
goes but I can hit 5 out of 10 times and
and Dennis who played semi-pro hockey or
used to goes excuse me excuse me because
he's eccentric ah he has no idea yeah
and he goes I think I can hit five out
of ten and and then I said from here you
could take that puck and hit the top I'm
talking about the top of the goalpost
the bar and he goes yeah well Wayne did
it six out of ten oh yeah
like oh my greatest ever pick up a
[ __ ] yeah and apparently the pause in
the fastest skater didn't have the heart
fastest slot he just was a beast
yeah just understood the game's beast
like you know there's Messi this Ronaldo
there's Pele there's Jordan there's
Barry Sanders Joe Montana Jerry Rice
Wayne gutsy they pick one swing good
look at the records like oh you know
it's a flower Dickens uh forget what you
did what yeah any key they got what the
guys are doing now like point that up
they're not even close no he's so
[ __ ] good yeah
that's so sick in it crazy yeah I mean
he's what he's six feet or something and
and create and just create a smoke show
of a dog yes whose hands are looking
easel ain't seen ain't seen his daughter
we had seen it so he's six you'll see
see how she's dating a golfer
of course what see if car so I just say
dumb things sometimes well [ __ ] you get
a little bit of trouble what happened uh
that she was like he got mad at she was
posting and risky [ __ ]
oh she's she'd be my one healthy box am
i right well now that she married a guy
we do know she married a guy who looks a
lot like her dad right a little bit some
angles uh maybe the same knows she's
she's a beauty
yeah she's a dime you dime
you know I mean I'll get pregnant our
boy but would your boy Ryan Bader
married a very wealthy smoke show she
comes from a long line of like some
she's got a lot of money Bader did yep
how do you know I know people who know
him and they were talking about how
awesome his wife is but also how wealthy
her family is and interesting yeah that
Bader's a super dimepiece - he's a stud
by the way correct again damn look at
them look at that is that Beyonce next -
no that's Sierra you racist [ __ ] it's
hard to see though not at all okay
who is Sierra sorry she's seen that
football player
no she's married with a kid of Russell
Wilson said that starting quarterback
Seattle Seahawks Russell Wilson did
pretty well how about your boy Marshawn
Lynch making a comeback I know right
yeah doing the damn boy Tariq worked out
I'm ready sessions yeah yeah our boy
tarde got Marshawn Lynch ready yep
I'm so fine dad yes so Sierra where's
was made I'm just gonna educate you old
ass mm-hmm hey boomer check it so Sierra
I got she good-looking oh my god you
seen in person what the [ __ ] is going on
and she could sing and she can dance
what it hold on that's ridiculous
never seen before huh no she she was
made to a guy named future Iraq she was
just with him I know that a critical
feature is that a kid I know whose baby
future is also future and now Russell
Wilson has a rule in training camp you
know they played music during practice
you can't play any future songs he
[ __ ] right you can't and they don't
play future songs
[ __ ] you future future create some hits
though is the myth
Russell Wilson such a baller he's so
[ __ ] good he's so good he'd be my MVP
again really with much yeah or if you
had to put your money on it right now
Lamar Jackson all day who wins you know
heard of him that's what it well I I
know I have how about how about a Henry
the running back for ten Titans man oh
my god you know if you wanted yes oh I
was watching the highlights what are you
such a beast so big and so fast and so
ridiculous oh my
god mm-hmm oh yes here this body the
[ __ ]
uh well look at her face Russell Wilson
looks miserable there he's an athlete
like sponge Oh athlete eat that [ __ ] up
man yeah yeah he likes to blow to this
[ __ ] oh that's happy there he's kid you
can
that's futures kid they have the way and
Versace that's futures kids unless you
need ads named like he looks miserable
there again yeah
she's tall by the way how tall is
Russell he's not tall six months
he's what gave all the small guys
besides drew brees oh yeah he's all I
thicker than breeze doesn't either
looks like he's a thick fella it's
thicker well I don't leaven now yeah
he's small
that's because being under six foot was
a big deal that fighting you're drafted
first like Carson Wentz all those guys
are so tall six six of course when it's
nowhere near as good as him Kyler Marie
510 drew Brees six foot you don't want a
real big quarterback well it's too long
to release the football huh but a lot of
really good ones Hart all new blood show
all those guys were all tall let's hold
on yeah no yes 1993 yeah no I know
yeah yeah I'll get back though all right
cool no but listen but they've always
been tall like Randall Cunningham was
really totally here we go person yeah no
DC Ramakant oh no those are only
references at article yeah I got you I'm
Annie Peyton Manning big big guys yeah
so Tom Brady old old old old but but so
also think of change changing a little
was short and small yes cuz to be people
are like oh you get you have to be big
and tall play quarterback and then drew
Barry said hold my [ __ ] right hold my
birthmark
yeah and [ __ ] it started playing ball oh
my birthmark hold my birthmark now so
he's he's six foot maybe that's being
generous I'm a home my home is six three
we got our boy from who plays for Green
Bay in Roger Aaron Rodgers 6-3 but again
the Drew Brees Drew Brees calimary
Russell Wilson Lamar Jackson the March
is not Tom's not huge no he's small
that's why Marv Jackson I'm gonna say is
at least six to
I'd say 6 1 that's why they're worried
they taking so many hits because I'm big
dude what's his longevity yeah
6 dear so that means 6 months yeah
Michael Vick 6 foot you know yeah yeah
their age of the real token hey I'm
still gonna say the average is 6 3 maybe
no I'd say average yeah that's right
yeah 3 6 2 yeah but what not 6 6 not 6 7
no my point is is you you can be small
be a super ball right cuz I thought it
was going to how so real to me Russell
will should be MVP really yeah plays in
the toughest division there's no you
know doesn't have a ton of help the the
you know why didn't you ever play
linebacker I don't know man I don't care
why did you play deep how about you suck
this oh yeah you suck my dick why did
you say why didn't you play defense it'd
be so hard
why don't you play quarterback hut hut
hike hike hike ha ha hi
I let me pee real quick I got a
pissed-off spirit hissing quietly secure
your hips hey once you play hockey
because I didn't want to yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]